you mentioned prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him we know he's the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
but when you bring this up
to
certain people to let's say the
christians some of them and how would
you answer this they try to compare him
to like a joseph smith and the mormons
who they reject they say oh this is just
another sect just like we have the
mormons
mormons or members of the church of
jesus christ of latter-day saints are a
religious group who practice mormonism
the origin of mormonism dates back to
the 1820s when joseph smith the founder
of the religion published the book of
mormon which he claimed he translated
from ancient egyptian writings on golden
plates that an angel showed him in
manchester new york mormonism teaches
the trillions of planets scattered
throughout the cosmos are ruled by
countless gods who once were human like
us
the latter-day saints hope to prove
their worthiness and thus become gods
believe you're gonna become a god one
day
yeah why
it is in the scriptures and the prophets
have where
it's all throughout the scriptures where
have you heard this argument
hey baby are you an angel because i'm
allergic to feathers
you know how to get them
hey baby did you just fart because you
blew me away
[Applause]
no matter what technology the church
comes out with they can never beat the
power of the knock what is a celestial
girl like you doing in a terrestrial
place like this
that's a good one
you're ready for byu
byu i do
sure so the first foremost thing is if
we look at the mormon church and and
what was developed there and so on uh
and other sects that you have in
christianity and false prophets and
things
we show a distinction between that and
the prophet muhammad peace and blessings
upon him in first and foremost the quran
the book of mormon and again with no
disrespect to mormons i have it i've
read it i've gone through it you will
find
many things that
are not in accordance to what modern
science has found today
you will find many things that would be
uh i would say racially uh unacceptable
for us to stay today and i don't want to
go too deep unless you want to go down
that rabbit hole no but
but you can look at the writings of
bingham young and you can write about
the mark of kane and uh how black skin
was a curse brought and things like this
that today if you really want to discuss
um you know you couldn't say these would
be the teachings of a true prophet right
you don't find any actual historically
verified miracles you don't find any
scientific facts that scientists
joseph smith could not have known at the
time and
found out later we find all those
miracles in the life of the prophet
peace and blessings be upon him first
and foremost sign that shows that he was
a true prophet is the quran itself
we challenge christians and say look
tell us this
how can a man in the desert who doesn't
know how to read or write
according to the historians across the
board from ibn's
you go back to the scholars
muslims and orientalists you will find
that
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
was illiterate unlettered couldn't read
or write how could he then write a book
that was so eloquent that none of the
poets of arabia could answer that none
of them could bring anything like it and
they tried i have a series on the life
of the prophet peace and blessings be
upon him and we show evidences historic
evidences of those poets that tried and
failed
to show that nobody could bring
illiterate literally work that would
have such balara excellence in speech
right
not just that the quran talks about the
sun and the moon and the planetary
bodies being in an orbit
you know till very recently scientists
were were saying that the sun doesn't
have an orbit i mean the sun and
very recently they said you know it does
it's a very slow orbit but it does have
an orbit how could a man in a desert who
didn't know astronomy who didn't have
access to the works of the greeks and
the romans and all of this
even the greeks and romans didn't know
these things how could he have known
that okay somebody could say maybe he
guessed at it okay no problem you guess
once you get it right i got it
but then
you have multiple miracles like that
scientific facts how salt water and
seawater touch but don't makes how
mountains have pigs that go on the
ground
things that he wasn't a geologist he
didn't the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him we don't have any evidence that
he ever went to a place that had salt
water
what was around him it was all sweet
water so how would he know there's waves
under the ocean how would he know these
thing how could he guess every time and
get it right
not just that there are historic
prophecies you see like like when you
put all of these together it becomes a
numeric
fact
that this could not have been without
divine intervention and i'll explain
this
so there's scientific miracles
then there are
linguistic miracles
as we talked about then there are
prophecies about the romans and persians
and battles and who would win that came
true even if you look at the prophecies
of the prophet muhammad peace in the
quran in hadith when he talked about the
the victory of constantinople today we
call it istanbul right how would you
have known that the victories over the
persians how would he have known that at
a time where he didn't even control the
arabian peninsula at the time in khandak
when all the different arab tribes were
attacking medina there was the fear that
the muslims would be genocided to be
finished by the arabian tribes he was
telling them we will have contact he
will prophesizing these things and those
came true one after the other every one
of them
how do you guess every time and get it
right
and then there are physical miracles and
i have a video especially about this and
i think me and you spoke about this
before about the splitting of the moon
right
today if we go i mean amongst the mormon
church they still have prophets they
have people that they call prophets
right and there are many other uh
christian denominations that have
prophets i will i will challenge any one
of them come meet me in san diego and
we'll go out on a clear night and i'll
point at the moon and i'll ask them
split the moon for me
right can they do it
i don't think so right the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
during his lifetime the the mushrikeen
the eight the the politists of mecca
they told him show us a miracle he said
what do you want he says split the moon
and this is the quran
in the first ayah
and he
pointed and allah made it that the moon
split now again this sounds
like a very wild claim i understand but
we will bring extraordinary evidence for
this
right
we're not just saying it's in the quran
we believe it no like for example moses
split the ocean okay we believe it but
if we ask jews to show historic evidence
we don't have it right if you talk about
jesus walking on water if you talk about
first-hand reports that can be verified
through change of narration you don't
have it
right
in islam
we will show that the people who were
eyewitnesses
who were from different cities abdullah
ibn abbas it was in mecca
malik at this time he was in madinah
now each one of these eyewitnesses we
can give you their historic profile
meaning we can tell you what was their
name their father's name their mother's
name their children how was their memory
where they lived where were they born
where did they die how good was their
precision of reporting we called up and
adal all of us not just that who did
they
share this information with
who was the one that reported from them
who wrote it down who were the scholars
of hadith
not just that
these are from not just the companions
of the prophet peace be upon him but
even the enemies of the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him now imagine eddie if
i'm in balboa park and i'm having a
debate and i tell guys hey you know what
i can split the moon right or i can
split the sun okay
maybe the people on my side i hope not
but maybe some of them will back me just
because it's a partisan thing right
but my enemies were debating against me
no way they're going to be like we got
him finally we got him you know he
didn't do it we didn't see it right they
would make a big fuss out of it
the enemies of the prophet peace be upon
him who were the polytheist idol
worshipers of mecca
they admitted that yes this happened
imagine that
nobody from that historical time denied
it
right it's in the quran meaning it was
recited in front of the politics for
years after that none of them said no we
were in mecca and it didn't happen we
challenged christians atheists jews
hindus whoever else to bring us one
single report of anybody from that time
period whether he was a muslim a
polytheist or not that said no i was in
mecca and this did not happen we will
bring multiple reports from abu sufyan
who was not muslim at that time from
abuja and walid
and others who never became muslim that
died as enemies of islam but they still
admitted yes
this did happen
so how does a false prophet bring
something like this
just yeah and you have the the mormon
prophets they're making predictions of
the end of times is going to come but
then that date comes and passes you
don't have these things with prophet
muhammed peace and blessed be upon you
wake up there are over 300 million
americans that don't know what islam is
this is why we are opening the dean
center the first of its kind 35 000
square foot tawa center and masjid to
show america the beautiful message of
islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch nationwide programs a
state-of-the-art production studio for
online content and an on-site dawah
center to show what true islam is donate
right now may god almighty allah reward
all of you
[Music]
you